hey there my name is Cameron welcome to
3d camera techniques today you are going
to learn pro skills and become a master
of the 3d camera inside of After Effects
without these techniques your motion
design will lack dimension and no one
wants flat motion design so let's dive
in and get started
this is motion science
let's begin with the 3d camera setup
start with a new camera by going to
layer new camera or use the shortcut
command option shift C if you're on a
Mac in the camera settings window there
are two areas that need to be focused on
the first area is the camera type drop
down and this drop down either a one
node or a two node camera can be
selected the only difference between
these two types of cameras is the way
they orient a one-note camera Orient's
around itself
[Music]
a two node camera Orient's around the
point of interest
[Music]
you may be asking yourself which camera
mode should I use the answer is simple
start with the camera type that feels
most comfortable to you camera settings
can be changed at any time to fit the
needs of evolving motion design so
you're never locked into one set camera
[Music]
the second area of importance in the
setup window are the presets presets are
named according to focal lengths each
one is meant to represent the behavior
of a real-world camera
each camera preset has different
variables
the preset sets the angle of you zoom
focus distance
focal length and aperture values
each camera preset has different
variables for example the 15 millimeter
preset has a very wide field of view
[Music]
whereas the 80 millimeter preset has a
very narrow field of view
[Music]
[Music]
the best way to navigate the camera
inside After Effects is 3d space is to
utilize the view layouts in the view
layouts there are multiple options for
viewing a scene two views horizontal and
vertical
for views
[Music]
four views left
right and so on
once inside of you lay out a 3d pop-up
is chosen for the angle of view 3d
pop-up views can be from the front left
top and so on also there are three
custom 3d pop-up views that display a
bird's eye perspective in any view the
camera can be tracked on X
[Music]
why
or Z to fine-tune the perspective
but in the custom views the camera can
also be oriented in addition to tracked
a pro tip is to use the active camera
view to create cuts within the scene
[Music]
with two or more different cameras in
the same timeline the active camera view
tells after-effects to cut to whatever
camera the time indicator is above
[Music]
to control the 3d camera go to the tool
window where the camera controls are
located the first camera tool is called
the unified camera tool it replicates
the camera controls found in popular 3d
programs where a three-button mouse is
used the left center and right button
each have individual camera controls
assigned to them without a three button
Mouse use the additional camera tools
found beneath the unified camera tool by
selecting each of these tools and
holding down the mouse button the camera
can orbit
track on X&Y
and track Anzhi
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
each of these camera tools can be
accessed more quickly by using the
shortcut C on the keyboard each press of
the C key will cycle through the next
camera tool
[Music]
every property of the 3d camera can be
animated by setting keyframes to set a
keyframe click on the stopwatch of the
desired property and then add two or
more keyframes to that property for the
camera to move in between
by keep rhyming the position and
rotation properties the 3d camera can
emulate real-world camera techniques
like scene in the following examples
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to have more individual control over the
position properties of the camera a pro
tip is to control click the position
property and then select separate
dimensions by doing this each position
property is now a separate property and
can be independently keyframed
[Music]
the path between keyframes that the 3d
camera follows is called a motion path
motion paths default to a linear line
but can be adjusted to be more
interesting by simply adding Bezier
curves by going to the tool window and
selecting the pin tool drop down menu
the convert vertex tool can be selected
with this tool click and drag on any key
frame and Bezier handles will appear
adjusting the Bezier handles can help
create more interesting motion paths for
the camera to follow a pro tip is to use
the auto orient function found under
layer transform Auto Orient
the camera will orient its perspective
along the motion path that it follows
motion paths between keyframes default
to a constant rate of speed the graph
editor in After Effects represents this
constant rate of speed as a straight
line keyframe assistance can slow down
the rate of speed in relation to key
frames to make camera motion less
jarring select the position property
keyframes and go to animation keyframe
assistant easy ease an alternative
shortcut is to ctrl click the keyframes
and select keyframe assistant easy ease
the motion between keyframes is now
represented as an arc in the graph
editor instead of a straight line the
speed is no longer constant and the
motion is less jarring
[Music]
the camera speed starts at zero quickly
builds up to 100% and then quickly slows
back down to a speed of zero
by clicking on a keyframe handle and
dragging left or right the speed art can
be refined even more
[Music]
from for simple modes of keyframe
assistant easing multiple interesting
speed variations can be made
[Music]
NOLs can be used as camera rigs to add
secondary motion to already establish
keyframes with the camera selected go to
layer camera create orbit Knoll the
camera is now parented to a null located
in the center of the scene keyframe the
camera to rotate on its z-axis
[Music]
also keyframe the orbit Knoll to rotate
on its y-axis
[Music]
the camera movement is getting
interesting to make the camera movement
even more exciting add a wiggle
expression to add this expression option
click on the position property of the
camera and type the text wiggle
parenthesis 5 comma 25 parentheses press
enter on the numeric keypad or click
outside the expression box to enable the
expression the camera now has a handheld
feel to it on top of its already
established motion a pro tip is to take
this one step further by controlling
when the expression effect happens add
another no layer to the timeline by
going to layer new null then with the no
layer selected add the effect expression
controls slider control add another
instance of the slider control rename
the first slider frequency and the
second slider amplitude
[Music]
now highlight the number five and pick
whip it to the first slider
highlight the number 25 and pick whip it
to the amplitude
[Music]
by keyframing the frequency and
amplitude sliders the expression can be
controlled
[Music]
if you're asking yourself can any number
be plugged into this expression the
answer is yes lower numbers will have
more subtle shake while higher numbers
will create more intense shake
[Music]
[Music]
motion blur and After Effects simulates
the blur found when real world cameras
capture on film computer-generated
imagery or CG can have a very hard-edged
look to it motion blur is a subtle but
very effective technique that helps to
soften the hard edge and add realism add
motion blur by first enabling the switch
set for all layers in the timeline
then activate the motion blur button
just above the layers in the timeline a
pro tip is to increase or decrease the
amount of motion blur in a composition
by going to composition settings and
clicking the Advanced tab under this tab
settings can be adjusted for shutter
angle shutter phase samples per frame
and adaptive sample limit each motion
blur examples seen here has slightly
different settings and has a unique
motion blur
[Music]
the 3d camera has many options available
to it zoom like in a real camera makes
the image appear closer or further away
depth of field brings the image pixels
in and out of focus enable depth of
field by switching it on under the
options drop-down or by double-clicking
on the camera and enabling it in the
settings window focus distance is the
distance from the camera to the focus
plane aperture helps to bring more or
less dimension to a scene by increasing
or decreasing it blur level is the
amount of blur in the depth of field 100
percent is a natural blur based on the
camera preset the Irish shape defaults
to fast rectangle a pro tip is to stick
with the fast rectangle whenever
possible the other Irish shapes do have
interesting characteristics but render
much slower than the fast rectangle all
of the Irish settings are options for
fine-tuning the shape of the iris and
highlight gain threshold and saturation
all have to do with boosting luminosity
on out-of-focus pixels a second Pro tip
is to use the preset expressions found
under layer camera the first link focus
to point of interest
does just that
the expression sets the cameras focus
distance to its point of interest
link focus distance to layer sets the
focus to the distance between the
cameras position and another layer or in
other words this expression creates auto
focus
[Music]
and set focus distance to layer sets the
focus distance at the current time - the
distance at the current time
in this lesson we explored how to set up
the 3d camera how to control the 3d
camera how to add first and secondary
motion and how to adjust the numerous
options to help make the camera work for
you now that you know the techniques to
master the 3d camera it's time to put
that knowledge into action practice
makes perfect and the more you practice
the better you will become as a motion
designer I would love to hear your
thoughts about this lesson so please
make sure to leave a comment below
thanks for taking the time to watch and
until next time I'm Cameron and this is
motion science
you